fang an es geht um das thema so
vermeiden sie ärger bei der reisebuchung
für die herbstferien ganz ganz wichtiges
thema tipp 1 soll es ins ausland gehen
empfehle ich tatsächlich buchen sie eine
pauschalreise
der vorteil wenn es eine reisewarnung
gibt wird die abgesagt
höchstwahrscheinlich zumindest und sie
bekommen aber auf jeden fall ihr geld
wieder
tipp 2 vorsicht bei individual buchungen
da sind sie oft nur auf die kulanz der
anbieter angewiesen und wenn ihr flug
trotzdem geht und sie aber nicht reisen
wollen oder können müssen sie
wahrscheinlich trotzdem gerade auch bei
billigairlines den vollen preis bezahlen
und bekommen nichts zurück dann tipp 3
lassen sie sich von den kostenlosen
umbuchungen verschiedener
fluggesellschaft nicht blenden das
klingt auf den ersten blick erstmal
super wollen sie aber dann einen flug zu
einem hochpreis termin buchen müssen sie
kräftig draufzahlen also auch da
wirklich vorsicht tipp 4
buchen sie lieber bei den
fluggesellschaften selbst wir haben das
sehr oft erlebt dass gerade ausländische
reisebüros opodo die rückzahlung
tatsächlich deutlich verzögern und da
weiß man auch nicht ob das geld jemals
kommt und fünf jedes urlaubsland könnte
wir haben es gemerkt zu einem
risikogebiet erklärt werden und insofern
werde auf nummer sicher gehen will
tatsächlich wirklich immer deutschland
buchen wenn sie denken jetzt ist
portugal vielleicht ein gutes gebiet
auch da könnte sich die lage relativ
schnell ändern